david is with us in shreveport to start
off this hour hi david how are you
i'm fantastic how are you sir better
than i deserve what's up
i am a 1099 contractor and have been for
close to five years
and i've been trying to uh increase my
opportunities
in the same company and i applied for a
position that's still a 1099
uh and then they sent me back a a
disclosure or non-disclosure
agreement as well as a statement in
there that says that uh should anything
ever go on i would not be able to speak
in any way negative about the company or
anyone in the company forever
not just like in a non-disclosure or a
non-compete clause or anything like that
but forever
and so i i kind of got some red flags on
that one
um and i'm trying to figure out if this
is something that i should even
try and consider to pursue or if this is
something that just sounds
way too out there or too much to be
asking if somebody to not
be able to talk freely about something
that would happen years down the road
[Music]
that's a fascinating question yeah
um well i uh
i don't know why you would want the
freedom
to bash somebody i was just thinking
yeah
i mean you know you know um if
especially you've been there five years
and you haven't seen anything that needs
bashing
because you're signing up for another
you're signing up for a longer trip
right
yes sir so you don't have any indication
that this is a bunch of crazy people or
something
and so um if a legal matter ever came up
those are excluded out of these things
not a legal matter criminal right yeah
yeah a legal matter would be it would
not be excluded but a criminal
if someone uh is involved in uh
uh you know i don't know some kind of uh
i'm trying to think i don't drug use or
stealing money or something
or uh extortion yeah you would that's um
you know criminal is separate from civil
and nda cannot cover criminal john's
right
um so i i don't know if i'm just trying
to put
my feet in your moccasins and walking
through it for a minute
here's the thing i don't um i've got
uh i i don't reserve
the right i don't um
have a tendency to trash people that
i've worked with
um i guess i have too i've trashed a few
not not employers but
um vendors that misbehaved i've done
that
um you know for instance i think
marriott sucks
as an example so um you know
and uh so i you know what do you what do
you there's something
like i was planning that i just didn't
know what to do with it i didn't yeah
yeah
it's just it it bothered you i'm just
trying yeah
it's not that you're planning it but i'm
trying to think of what situation you
would be in where you
here's the thing in our i'll tell you
what's running through my mind and i'm
i'm a little bit of the
victim of this to say the least um
and that is is that uh everybody in our
culture today seems to think they're an
activist
and it's like your job to straighten
everybody else's life out
on social media and that's what they're
trying to prevent
and like you know your job is to uh
publicly reprimand your employer
um which if you do that here i'll fire
your butt
because if you're gonna pee in the
cereal i mean right because it tastes
bad
um i'm gonna fire you okay i pay you
money to feed your family
and if you're gonna run me down you know
in on social media or your wife is i'm
gonna fire your little stupid activist
butt
and you deserve to be fired and so
that's what's running through my mind
honestly and i'm trying to think
of um and you should be fired i mean
you're disloyal you're a horrible
employee you know and uh when you tear
down the very place that's giving you
money that's ridiculous and so you
you're not the kind of guy's going to do
that but this these are the kinds of
things that are probably running through
their mind they run through my mind too
uh because i've i've had to do that um
and i'll i'll look to to future you
david
and tell you in the past when i have
talked negatively about a former
employer
the only negativity that gets spread
around is on me
yeah yeah it looks it looks foolish and
stupid
um and small and so man
if if you really have a really ugly
negative experience
10 and 10 years from now someone asks
you you can say yeah i used to work
there
i don't like to talk about it people
will get the message right and you don't
have to go into gory
details and all that nonsense um it just
makes you look small
yeah that's true that's true i don't
think you're
i don't think you're losing anything
unless your intention is to be some kind
of an activist which i wouldn't support
you in doing that
so no you know not my intention i didn't
i didn't hear that i didn't i didn't i
mean i heard your spirit's pretty clear
in your voice i hear it clearly
so yeah yeah i i don't see a problem
with it i
i um you know i'm trying to think of
times that someone has presented an nda
to me
um i signed an nda when a good friend of
mine
brought me the idea for the total money
makeover
and he wanted before he disclosed the
idea of that book to me
he wanted to me and i said dude i don't
i'm not going to steal it
and i you know if that is good we're
going to do it so that's fine i signed
it i didn't think anything about it
and obviously it's turned out i've sold
eight nine million copies of that book
so it turned out to be a good nda
a good idea and i protected him on the
idea he made a lot of money we made a
lot of money everybody's
been a lot got a lot of help so that's
when i did sign one
um and i've signed him when i've left
you signed one when you came to work
here but i was a
high level leader and yeah there's trade
secrets blind closed doors there's
attitudes buying
yeah all kinds of just private stuff
proprietary information
yeah and that kind of stuff but i'm
trying to think when i have
oh i'll tell you when i've been
unwilling to sign an nda is if somebody
that just calls and asks for a meeting
here
and they have and i've never heard of
them and i don't know them and they've
got this idea that they want to bring us
and i just go you know i don't really
want to know about your idea
because ideas are a dime a dozen people
who can pull them off for zero
and so uh there's not many and so i
don't i don't really want to
get into cause we've got people all over
this building with ideas and we may have
already had the idea that you're
bringing in here so i don't want to
convolute the waters with that so that's
a time that i've not done it
um because i there i get people pouring
ideas across our desks every day around
here
inside the building we don't have to do
that and we don't we're not known for
stealing ideas in the marketplace so
um you know that's the other thing so i
yeah
i would sign it i would sign it unless
you've got something in that
company that you think there's something
bad going on and they're just trying to
trap you in a sense but you've been
there five years you wouldn't be
ready to continue the relationship if
you thought that
so that's an interesting question it
gives me pause and makes me want to stop
and think
yeah yeah so and if you see something
that you don't like
that's when you've got to be the
grown-up and say i'm out yeah or i'm
going to stay
tap out and you all have a choice i
don't you know i had a
company i was working for when i was in
my 20s and i said this is the way it's
going to be and i said
oh no it's not and they said yes it is
and i said no it's not going to work
have a great
work here anymore yeah have a great
afternoon it's america it's not russia
yeah you know and i don't have to be
here anymore